foreign
[Music]
swanstrom I'm at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill and I'm going to
speak today about resistance to
derunivir which we call a fifth
generation HIV protease inhibitor
this slide will be familiar to many of
you it's
represents the time course for HIV
infections the orange line is the viral
load the amount of virus that's in the
blood and you can see there's an initial
viremia over the first few weeks that
is then controlled down to a set point
but during that set point in the black
line you can see there's a continual
loss of CD4 T cells which are the target
cells for viral replication and when
those cells become low enough their
result is immunode deficiency get an
onset of symptoms including a modest
increase in viral load which is one of
the opportunistic infections that gets
advanced in the state of immune and
deficiency but along with other
opportunistic infections this will
ultimately lead to death so the goal
then is to control this infection and
allow people to live longer normal lives
and the way we've done that successfully
is with therapy and therapy is able to
lower the viral load to basically
undetectable levels with normal
laboratory tests and keep the viral load
low and we'll discuss why that is in a
minute but successful therapy can go on
for the life of the person and it's
really been one of the major medical
success stories that we've had
yeah
there's a goal to have a cure for HIV in
which case the virus would be
functionally gone and a person could
stop therapy there'd be no virenia no
rebound and those are important studies
that are ongoing success is unknown at
this time but it's uh the next major
Frontier for HIV
the bad thing that can happen with
therapy is that you can get rebound
going back to your set point and the
continuation of the disease course and
rebound occurs either by stopping the
drugs or if there's therapy failure
which is that the virus develops
resistance and that's what we're going
to talk about today
so the
very successful study that occurred with
HIV was that I
the use of three potent drugs relatively
potent drugs was able to fully suppress
viral replication and this is the key
paper from that study now some years ago
but it really was showed the path to how
we can provide people with successful
therapy and allow them to control virus
for a long time and what you're seeing
here is people starting therapy and the
average drop in viral load now the
important thing is that the viral load
in the lowest line goes down and stays
down
whereas the other two lines the first
one with the open triangles was actually
two drugs two older drugs AZT and CTC
here it's Adobe Dean and the methodine
um you get a suppression of virus
initially but then you see viral rebound
load goes back up and that's indicative
of the virus replicating in the presence
of these drugs and since they're potent
enough to control replication somewhat
the outcome is really resistance to
these drugs and then this the field
circles represent the third drug that
made this overall successful but one
given by itself you can see that it's
ultimately it's initially potent reduces
viral load but then the virus comes back
up and again with resistance but when
you put these three drugs together you
get suppression so
here we have the azt3tc these are chain
terminating nucleoside analogs for
inhibiting reverse transcriptase
the uh what I'll call a second
generation HIV produce in a very in
denevere again potent but not successful
in suppressing replication completely
but then the three drugs together are
successful in suppressing viral
replication
that is the Paradigm that we use for
control and HIV infection now
so what's really going on what does
suppression really mean and what it is
is that you're shrinking the viral
population in this initial period of
therapy
such that there's not enough viral
diversity in these reduced populations
to allow for the successful Evolution or
linkage of resistance mutations on one
viral genome so you can see that with
these separate drugs there are either
pre-existing or evolving mutations in
the presence of the drugs that allow the
virus with the mutation to grow back out
with the three drugs you're providing a
genetic barrier that the virus just
can't overcome no one viral genome is
able to accumulate resistance mutations
to all of these drugs and therefore the
population shrinks further and further
so there's no replication and a little
bit of virus that is present is actually
being produced from cells that are
latently infected
not replicated virus
so the goal then is to create this High
genetic barrier and what we're going to
talk about today is protease Inhibitors
you can see that the second generation
protease inhibitor was potent but not
able to suppress replication by itself
as we get to the discussion of what
fifth generation produce Inhibitors are
I'm always hoping that they will be so
effective with this High genetic barrier
that they could be used as single drug
therapy there's some evidence that for
some people that would work it's not a
slam dunk yet that this is going to turn
out that way but certainly we'll look at
what high genetic barrier is for a
highly potential
so there's the goal no replication no
Evolution when you fully suppress
firewall repetition
now
this is the life cycle of retroviruses
they bind to the cell enter and what's
most real special about retroviruses is
that they copy their RNA genome into DNA
and that starts in the cytoplasm and
eventually gets copied into the single
stranded RNA to double-stranded DNA that
then is integrated into the host genome
now most of our Inhibitors of them that
are used in people today are Inhibitors
of reverse transcriptase in the
integration inhibitors
I showed you that the protease inhibitor
was key in defining a paradigm where you
could fully suppress replication but in
reality today the most potent drugs are
most likely to use drugs are inhibiting
reverse transcription and the
integration step we do have good
protease Inhibitors they're just not the
go-to drugs for
that are most widely used these days but
these things come and go and it's
possible that protease Inhibitors as
they become even more potent will in
fact come back and so I think it's
worthwhile to understand what the
potential is
okay what we're going to look at today
is where the protease comes into play
and that's where protease Inhibitors
work so the viral proteins are
synthesized and I'll show you that
they're actually synthesized the ones
with
large speakers those prescriptions have
to be complete during and after release
of the virus from the cell and those
thick events are required to make mature
solar proteins that are active form of
the Imperium proteins and the viral
protease is responsible for that
and what you see here is the Assembly of
a virus particle with the major
structural protein which is called Gay
and gag is this multi-domain protein
over here it's a single poly protein and
you can
with gag alone you can Bud a virus
particle out of the cell it's not
infectious
but you can make particles so what you
need to do is to cleave up all of these
domains so that they can function
independently and make an active
protease and that's accomplished by a
related protein called gag profile so
for every 20 gain molecules that made
the virus is able to make one gag propul
molecule and the gag propol has most of
the gag protein in and that's used
see this Matrix Blue Dot is used to
Target a tool membrane so that's where
the bunny takes place in the gag
propolis is
directed to the budding virus particle
in a similar way but there's just one
twentieth that would be relative to get
what gank profile has in addition to
what the gag has is it has the enzymes
that the virus needs to replicate so
you'll see reverse transcriptase in
integrates which are budded in the virus
particle and they're used when the virus
makes it into the next cell to carry out
viral DNA synthesis and then integration
into those DNA
what the protease does is to chop all of
these things up into the smaller
proteins that become the active protein
so you can see that the process of
making an infectious virus particle
requires the viral protease and that's
why they're a good Target for inhibiting
viral replication so here's another view
of how a virus particle is actually made
you can see on the top panels
mostly gag and some gag protocol are
budding out of the virus pinching off
the cell membrane at the plasma membrane
and finally pinch it off and then you
see the viral proteins being cleaved you
can see the green which is the capsule
protein it's blown up in the bottom here
the capsule protein gets released the
purple is called nuclear capsid it's
binding to the viral RNA and condensing
the viral RNA into a nuclear protein
complex the capsid protein then is
cleaved from the membrane and released
and then reforms around the condensed
nuclear capsule core to give a virus
particle that now has this cone shaped
structure that you're probably familiar
with from looking at electron microscopy
of HIV articles
this structure along with the enzymes
Universal transcriptase and integrates
are what are required for infection and
again the reverse transcript patient
integrates themselves have to be cleaved
out of the gay protocol precursor to
assume their active forms so all of
these proteins require processing by the
viral produce
so this is what the viral protease looks
like
um
because I don't have the animation quite
worked out right here but we'll get to
that in a second so the in the center of
the structure is the viral protease what
you see is the half of its blue and half
of its green and that's become it's
because it's a homo dimer the purple
thing in the middle is actually a bound
inhibitor so two subunits identical
subunits and then the other thing that's
shown are these two red stick structures
which are aspartic acids one from each
subunit playing towards the inhibitor
now if you look to the left you'll see
uh those two aspartic acids
drawn to imitate what they are in the
structure with one from the blue sub
green subunit and you can see those
aspartic acids at their ends are holding
a water molecule that's how this enzyme
the suspartic proteinase leaves the
peptide bond those two aspartic acids
hold the water molecule and that water
molecule is added across the target
peptide bond to hydrolyze that Bond and
break it so having that water molecule
is key to understanding how the protein
the protease is able to clean the
peptide bar so that's a mechanism for
non-specifically cleaving any peptide
bond and so what you have to imagine is
all of the structure of the inhibitor or
the substrate on either side of the
target peptide bond is how the protease
in essence reads the protein to decide
where to bleed we'll come back to the
edge here in a second now
on the
right in the animation they didn't do
very well and I apologize
um you'll see on the right now two
aspartic acids again the same aspartic
acids they're at the active site but now
looking at an inhibitor and what the
inhibitor has is a hydroxyl group and
the oh so rather than having these two
aspartic acids hold the water molecule
they're now grabbing onto this oh in the
inhibitor
basically thinking that they're whole
they're right in the middle of adding
water across the peptide bond so the
inhibitor is tricking the enzyme into
grabbing what would be the transition
state of the water molecule adding being
added to the peptide bond and you can
see in the purple structure in the
middle that there's that little thing
coming down towards the two aspartic
acids the red aspartic acid so that's
the same hydroxyl group that the each of
these Inhibitors has to make it very
potent in binding the protease these are
the the most potent drugs we have in
terms of their binding affinity for
their target
so now how do proteases recognize what
their targets are well
there are two parts of this question one
is there is actually sequential cleavage
you don't just randomly cleave all of
these processing sites so there is a a
process of how do you get ordered
cleavage of these different food sites
and then two how do you even recognize
them well we know at a minimum they have
to be exposed so they're on Loops
disordered regions that the protease can
get access to but if you look at these
cleavage sites on the left and the slash
in the middle is meant to to be the site
that where the protease
cleaves the peptide bond between those
two amino acids so you can see each of
the cleavage sites with four amino acids
Upstream four amino acids Downstream
using the single amino acid code
but even if you don't know the code you
can see that these sequences don't look
very much like each other
that's kind of an issue number one the
prettiest is recognizing it's a very
diverse sequences well they're diverse
in sequence but when they're Bound in
the protease they actually assume
similar structures with one exception
that we'll talk about but similar
structures in the active site to align
the site that's going to be cleaved over
those two aspartic acids
and my collaborators see you safer has
studied this for a long time and I'll
show you in a second what she's found in
the way these diverse sequences Buy
first I need to teach you uh
what the nomenclature is for how we talk
about potato sites so I'm showing you on
the the left here these five different
sites but we can talk about the
positions in the sites using this
nomenclature and so the site that gets
cleaved is also called the Sissel bond
which I might use sometimes but the on
the Upstream side the n-terminal side
the first amino acids Upstream for any
cleavage site is called P1 and then we
continued P2 P3 P4 and then Downstream
same numbering scheme but now with the
prime so the downstream approaches the
z-terminus of that protein is the
adjacent amino acid that becomes the new
n-terminus of the cleave protein just as
P1 becomes the c-germinus of the
Upstream group protein
is P1 Prime P2 Prime P3 Prime and we'll
use that manipulator a lot today
now what Celia did was to find
these peptide cleavage sites into an
inactive protease so she could see all
of these all of these cleavage sites
bound and what you see is that they have
this kind of back and forth structure
that we call a beta sheet so they're
um
they're all pretty much filling the same
space within connectors so this is
really important idea that there was
this straight envelope
until you've used that in design
and it also is useful for understanding
how the protease resistance especially
to Inhibitors that
straight outside of the substrate
envelope now there's just a little hint
here that I'll tell you just to give
away what's coming up next and that is
you'll see that the P2 position on the
lower left actually looks like it has
two knobs there's a reason for that and
I'll show you that in a second and that
is substrates are binding in two
different conformations that's actually
also true for P2 Prime and I'll show you
that
so here we have the protease being
cleaved and
there's one more point that I need to
make is um that
the P1 Prime position the position that
becomes the n-terminus of the downstream
protein will sometimes have a ProLine in
it and Proline is the worst amino acid
you want for a protease in fact often a
few times when you are cleaving against
a ProLine in nature there's a special
produce that does that I'll show you why
that is in a second but in fact the HIV
protease are retrovises in general have
to be able to cleave with a ProLine at
the P1 Prime position
and the reason for that is to do with
the gag precursor and what the proteins
become so here's the gag creatures or
the structures that were determined kind
of independently and then put together
and what you see is that between Matrix
and capsid
there's a ProLine that becomes the amino
Terminus of the key capsule protein and
that Proline is essential for the virus
because of the structural role that it
plays after cleavage so the protease has
to be able to plead with a P1 Prime
choline to generate an amino-terminal
Proline for capsule this is actually
conserved across retrovirus this is not
just HIV it's a fundamental feature of
the way the virus matures
and you can see this here on the capsic
dimer forms if you look down in that
orange circle you'll see P1 so that's
the proline that became the amino
germanus after cleavage of the capsid
and you can see that it's folded back to
create that light blue loop and it
interacts with a conserved aspartic acid
d51 in the capsule structure and again
this is conserved across retroviruses
for making the capsid structure the
mature structure after cleavage and so
protease is in a sense they don't have a
choice they have to be able to cleave
with the P1 Prime Proline
so what happens
here is what looks like the virus the
party is trying to add the super
molecule stream
Proline
and you can see the structure of proline
amino acid is the only amino acid that's
constrained that the amino group
in the peptide backbone is physically
connected both in the back the peptide
chain but also through this circular
structure with the adjacent carbon so
this just becomes very different
normally the what is here shown as CH
would have a straight chain
wouldn't interact with that amino group
directly but here you can see that it's
constrained and it makes it that much
harder to cleave to hydrolyze the
peptide bond on that side but again the
virus doesn't have a choice
however having that Proline there
as I alluded to earlier affects the
confirmation of the substrate in the
Proteus
and so you can see that here this kind
of wavy line that's going through the
faint lady line that's actually the beta
sheet of the peptide backbone of the
substrate sitting in the active site of
the protease and notice that I've tried
to color it there's a kind of a red
color and a green color so if you follow
the red color amino acids that's when
you have a P1 Prime choline a big black
stick there is the cleavage site
but when you have a P1 Prime Proline if
you look to the left you see a P2 so a
couple amino acids Upstream in this case
is very Gene but it's pointing off to
the left
and if you look to the right the P2
isoleucine with the red color is also
pointing to the left and so the protease
is trying to read the sequence of the
amino acids to figure out if this is the
cleavage site and it uses these things
called subsites in the protease which
here for the P2 amino acid you have the
S2 subside in the protease and it's
trying to read that S2 that P2 amino
acid in the S2 subside so it's got to
read that the spare Gene P2 looking to
the left and the isoleucine at P2 Prime
also playing it to the left
so the problem comes when you have a
leucine as a typical other P1 Prime
amino acid not constrained and as a
result of that
the orientation of the P2
and P2 Prime amino acids is different so
if you look at the green now
you'll see that P2 valine is actually
pointing to the right and the P2 Prime
glutamine is also playing to the right
so this is a different completely
different part of the S2 subside pocket
that these amino acids are interacting
with and that the protease has to be
able to read to identify the right
cleavage side so the proline is changing
the confirmation of these two people the
P2 and the P2 Prime and amino acids in
addition to being more difficult to
cleave and the protease has to be able
to do that so the protease becomes
bi-specific in its ability to recognize
the amino acids that are in the P2 and
P2 Prime positions because of the
requirement to be able to cleave next to
a P1 Prime Proline which is a concerned
feature of virus maturation
okay 38 centimeters so here's a protease
inhibitor here's a actually the sort of
the best protease inhibitor that's out
there this would be what we call the
fourth generation protease inhibitor and
you can see the P1 position it has a big
amino acid which the produce lights
Dental out I mean that they're not
really amino acids in an inhibitor but
the equivalent of phenomenaline you can
see that oh that I talked about that is
going to mimic the water molecule it's
going to replace the water molecule and
the two aspartic acids are going to grab
onto that water molecule that oh
thinking it's the water molecule in the
process of being added across the
peptide bond now you see the P One Prime
amino acid is something that looks a
little bit like leucine
long alphabetic carbon hydrogen atoms
and then the P2 Prime in this case is
just something big that's going to sit
in the S2 Prime subsite now I have to
try to make this as confusing as
possible when we talk about the fifth
generation predation Inhibitors it's a
series that were made Inhibitors that
was made in Dr shifter's lab and she
described them
P1 Prime amino acid will have different
chemical chemical constituents that are
referred to as R1 R1 R1 Two element
three
um
two and then the P2 will have that that
end piece out there which is nh2 into
renovir will get changed and we'll call
those the R2 positions of R2 one r two
two one up to r25 so those are the fifth
generation amino acids are parties
neighbors that we're going to talk about
here this isn't called an ec50 assay
um you can see that
the
Inhibitors sort of marched to the left
had potency and genevere is this ID B is
the least potent for the ec50 the amount
to inhibit half of partial application
and these various Generations move to
the left meaning they're more potent at
inhibiting viral infection and see the
black line is derinivir which is
apparently the most potent one
UMass III is one of these fifth
generation ones which is right in there
with
interviewer and then on the right you
can see that this UMass series of fifth
generation parties and leaders are at
least as potent or more potent than
doing a beer
so that's the ones we're interested in
and we're also interested in
um the pathways to resistance I should
point out that darunavir is especially
an especially important drug in that
it's drug level the drug levels in the
blood are very high relative to the
level needed to inhibit the virus so you
can get blood levels
the maximum amount when you take the
drug is transiently that are a thousand
times higher than the amount that you
need to inhibit fifty percent of the
virus and activity so it's a very
attractive drug in the sense that
has complex interaction with the target
you'll see it has a high genetic barrier
for resistance and the drug levels get
very highly provided so we want to take
those advantage of those features and
try to make it even more potent with
some other chemical modifications
so how do you select for resistance you
start off with a clone of HIV and it's
totally homogeneous oh so there's a few
passages so there's a little diversity
and then you raise the drug
concentration and the rare variants in
there that are a little bit resistant
are able to grow out so we grow the
virus a little bit more you get some
more diversity increase the drug
concentration and you know using this
color scheme you can see that you can
sequentially select for higher and
higher levels of drug resistance and so
this is what we do in the lab sometimes
takes a long time but we're able to
study the evolution of resistance now
what I want to point out to you is that
this is very different than taking a
very high dose of drug right away and
you take the drug you immediately
require this high level of resistance
for replication so where it might take
us a year to select for high level
resistance in the lab
you're starting therapy with these
potent drugs you only have a few days
before replication is set down shut down
so what we're doing here is very
different from what would happen in a
person
but it does allow us to look at what the
potential is for resistance in a person
uh with this drug
so then
the other thing to think about is
resistance mutations have a fitness cost
that's why they're not the wild type
sequence and once you get a resistance
mutation that has a fitness cost you
also have to then think about
compensatory mutations in the enzyme to
restore enzyme function so these two
types of mutations resistance mutations
and compensatory mutations
kind of complement each other as you
evolve of the selection for resistance
okay so here's the square root
experiment that we did with the renovir
and with a series of these UMass enzyme
or Inhibitors to try to find ones that
were
interesting properties relative to
derinivir you can see the kind of the
punctual elevation of drug the drug
level as passage the number it goes on
and to see that something's going on if
you look in panel B you'll see that the
average number of mutations for selected
cultures uh was about five
to 100 Danimal of drug concentration
starting around one nanomolar drug
concentration and then one up to about
10 when we went to greater than a
thousand nanomology greater than one
macronomy so you can see that there was
selection going on over the whole range
of drug concentrations that we used when
we asked in these cultures did
resistance go up
you looked at the earlier cultures we
did see some resistance but you can see
the linked lines show that the early
compared to the late resistance went up
and way off to the right is the level of
drug sensitivity that we got after
passage without any drug at all so
selection is going on over the entire
period of escalating drum concentrations
you can see the loss of infectivity in
panel D that is when you put on the same
amount of virus by mass the amount of
infection you get goes down because of
all these
mutations that have affected virus
Fitness you can see that under these
cultural conditions that the the virus
required it to was required to maintain
about one percent of its original
effectivity position arrive in these
selection cultures and finally in in E
then you can see that
the catalytic efficiency of the enzyme
of the uh x-axis is going down with
these mutations as the Ki or the
inventory constant goes up so that's
again an example of the enzyme itself
losing
catalytic efficiency or Fitness while
you're accumulating the resistance
so here are the the
series of drugs and looking at the P1
Prime the community here starts off with
this thing that looks a little bit like
leucine but then the UMass has two
series one where it gets a little bigger
than leucine that you see and then the
biggest one is even bigger than that so
basically we're going to treat the
darunavir like the bigger and compare it
to the biggest does this make a
difference in selection for resistance
and it does if you look at the ones that
have the small
R1
with the bigger they favor mutations at
position
84 in the protease and
in contrast if you use the biggest
side chain at this female prime position
we now favor mutations at position 50.
and show you what that means in the next
slide so 50 sits right over the top of
the protease in this Loop that we call
the flap whereas 84 sits off to the
right and of course these mutations
appear on both sides it's a homo diver
so the green mutation appears on the
blue side also so you'd have an 84
mutation on both sides and a 50 mutation
and both of those Loops in a real need
but those are where the positions are so
the major resistance Pathways that
Define these the use of against the the
bigger or the biggest
are interacting directly with
inhibitor so why are they different oh
they're they're different for an
interesting reason alone they need to
point out one more thing those are not
the only mutations those are just the
pathways and so what you see is we have
these two Pathways and now I've divided
up the mutations by the pathway and I
should point out that these each little
series of bars shows the frequency of
having that mutation in many cultures
given the certain Pathways so you see
that the frequency goes up and we've now
split up the culture so that
we're only looking at ones that fixed 50
in the lower part
in the East 84 and the upper part and
you want to ask the question do these
Pathways have other mutations that
distinguish them or after one such are
common
so you can see that when you get an 84
mutation you need uniquely get a 32
mutation
in front of the protease is only 99
amino acids long so there aren't that
many positions to work with so but there
is a compensatory mutation at position
32
directly linked to communication of 84.
conversely when you get a 50 mutation
you can see that the compensatory
mutations are basically right on the
flat
and so they're right around position 50
on that that little fat region so those
are the ones that seem to be most
closely linked to the two mutation
Pathways of either 84 or 50 as the major
resistance mutations
then what you have are a bunch of
mutations that are common to both
Pathways and we think of these as more
General
compensatory mutations that are
affecting enzyme activity so the major
mutations cause a hit on enzyme activity
or New York substrate body the mechanism
is and then these guys try to compensate
for that regardless of what it is that
the proteases are doing as well
mutations at these positions seem to
improve the activity of the enzyme and
contribute to the resistance
this is an interesting point
if you look here if you have a mutation
at 50
it doesn't matter if you
are the bigger or the biggest of the P1
Prime side chains you're pretty
resistant you'll see the ec50 is
aggravated so you're pretty resistant uh
to regardless of what the inhibitor is
at P1 Prime
so you might say well why not just use
50 all the time because if you look at
84 84 is pretty good against the bigger
R1 side chain of P1 Prime but it's not
very good against the really big biggest
P1 Prime side chain so
you could have 84 for either for R1 or
you could have 50 for R1 or R2 so why
not just have 50 for everything it turns
out there's a pretty simple answer to
that
and that is 50 has a much bigger Fitness
hit and so you can get an equivalent
level of resistance using 84 you would
use 84. and you can see that here
kind of buried where we tested the
fitness relatively infectivity for a
bunch of different protease inhibitor
resistance mutations and you can see
that 84 retain much of its infectivity
whereas 50 was really poorly infectious
so if you look back over to the left in
the gray bar when you have the big the
biggest R1 side chain the P1 Prime side
chain 84 just doesn't do it and so
you're forced to use 50. 50 pathway even
though 50 is not very fit
there's one last thing to point out
which is uh but the
R2 remember the the P2 Prime position
can also affect potency we don't see
that it just selects for resistance but
we do see that it affects potency and so
you can see that we've grouped two of
the R2 side change chains which have the
higher potency
okay
it's a bigger Ki value actually should
go the other way the lower Ki value
which means that it's more resistant in
this case so you can see that 50
um
across all of these
mutants whether it's 50 84 or a
combination of 50 plus 84. the r r 2 1
and the R23 are less
active they have worse kis whereas the
rt2 and the r25 are more active and even
regardless of which pathway the enzyme
uses you can see that the gray bars give
lower values meaning that they're still
more potent even though there's a lot of
resistance in the enzyme here that's
being tested and the reason for this is
actually pretty obvious of the
structures it's important part of why we
understand what makes interact with our
potency for drugs in general
so this is the weaker interaction and
you can see we're not looking at this
the end part of this P2 Prime position
or the R2 molecule and you see in the
pink
and purple
the end is interacting with the backbone
of the protease which is a green but
there are these little dots and those
dots are water molecules so water
molecules are mediating these
interactions with the protein the
protease backbone as part of The Binding
of the inhibitor to the protease now
doing this with water molecules isn't
that efficient they're just water
molecules have a lot of entropy and and
so this is not a very stable structure
in terms of maintaining these
interactions in contrast the ones that
are giving the lower Ki values you can
see that they're interacting directly
with the protease backbone without any
water molecules around
it turns out that there's a good
comparison for this and that is the
interaction of the protease substrates
with the backbone itself and you can see
that in this this actually what is the
optimal substrate for the protease one
Eclipse first and the fastest the SP2 NC
cleavage site there's a direct
interaction between the protease and its
substrate but it's through the backbone
of the protease no water molecules at
all so the more potent drugs
watermarks
so
I've shown that
you have a combined drug potency
suppressor location
efficiently to prevent the evolution
resistance and human sight in how we
develop Therapies
love stand HIV drug start reverse
transcriptase integrates but those of us
who work on price
cheering for the places
HIV produces black natural and the
precursor polyproteins to their active
mature forms that's sort of blocking the
processing of these polycryption
precursors they're stuck in these
pictures of forms and they can't get to
the mature active forms and that's why
produce Inhibitors won't
HIV protease is an aspartic proteinases
it's active side disease two aspartic
acids they're holding the water molecule
that gets added across the peptide bond
Inhibitors mimic the substrate with the
hydroxyl group to occupy the catalytic
ascartic acids these are making them
transition state analogs very tightly
binding
the produce must find two different
substrate conformations due to the need
to accommodate a P1 Prime curling this
interesting phenomenon of dual
specificity
selection for resistance to potent
protease Inhibitors leads to the
sequential addition of mutations I
showed you that mutations go up as you
go to higher and higher drug resistance
levels
and then small chemical changes in the
inhibitor affect both the resistance
pathway which I showed you the
difference between the 84 and the 50
Pathways depending on the size of the
side chain and then the residual potency
through direct interactions with the
background
that's it thank you very much